hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
I know I said that I was going to stop
for today but I literally can't I love
this game so much and I'm finally onto
something good here
where I'm about to break through
everything I'm about to unleash my
creativity and make this actually work
and I can't stop I haven't had this much
fun not just recording the game but
playing a game in a long long time I
love this so much oh man and I know
they're focused on other stuff besides
that getting what they need and they're
honestly surprisingly unstressed about
all this especially considering they got
to go down here and breathe in the the
contaminated oxygen and we got a little
bit of overflow over there but we'll get
through that soon enough eventually
anyway so he's got to get all the way
down there at least they have plenty of
oxygen to breathe I suppose so that is a
thing that does exist but once that's
done we'll have some extra water will
actually be creating water you know
creating water will be adding more water
to our water supply and then we will be
able to say that we did all we could do
and are amazing people Luke and just
like that I forgot about those but
that's okay because we don't need to
worry about that bada-bing bada-boom can
we get a higher priority on that tree
buddy bootloop okay so now that that's
done oh [ __ ] that's unreachable okay so
we actually got to destroy that [ __ ] and
then cancel that okay well that's fine
cuz then they'll be able to do that just
yeah yeah okay dad that makes more sense
I was dumb about that but thankfully
they they put up the other wall first
but we got a new arrival who we got it
can't dig it don't like that a scaredy
cat can't fight uncultured hi Allie
okay Allie I remember Anneli from
another video game that I played in the
past and you weren't too much of an
in okay la I'll give you a benefit of
the doubt le you can try your best at
this le do what you can't do le alright
so now that that's done we're gonna dig
that one to do a big big oh no better
then build a BB there and then we'll
have water flowing in and then we should
be we should be pretty good I'm hoping
anyway yeah breathe in that delicious
contaminated oxygen
some of them might get a disease from
all this but hopefully it won't be too
bad I mean we will eventually have some
sort of medication I just don't know
when I got a bill more bad but forgot
about that no power oh I forgot about
that they haven't built a new batteries
yet my refrigerator is power please it's
very hot apparently what I said
refrigerator 126 degrees o'clock dude
that's that's pretty hot that's pretty
hot bro there's too hot for my blood too
hot for this poor creatures blossom it
doesn't that power yet but as soon as
that connects there it will have power
and then we will need to make we will
definitely need to make these extra
batteries here and then probably some
more power generators just to be able to
make sure that the batteries are
operating a hundred percent
I'm gonna build I'm gonna build two more
of those and one more of these just
because I don't want to risk anything
getting in the way of that
because we're about to draw just
moodle's of power so how we doing we got
good food the oxygen is flowing freely
you got harvest for us the algae is good
we might actually be close to out of
algae which means we'll have to dig this
[ __ ] out okay
I don't like being close to out of algae
cuz that's death but we'll see we'll see
what happens we'll see what happens I'm
not saying we're close to death but I'm
saying being out of algae would be close
to death oh [ __ ] oh no come on now okay
good all right so I goof there the
plumbing has been down for a while cuz
I'm dumb
alright this got a priority of six not
nine okay all right so hopefully that'll
that'll do just fine I'm actually gonna
just in case I'm gonna drop these bad
boys down to six as well I'm gonna make
these top priority these one block off
to make sure no gas leaks in through
there then we should be okay
Oh Ruby are you trapped Wow okay you're
fine good all right then the thracian
medium is going to get there that should
be all set up that's good to go
that makes sense to me this will be done
soonish as soon as they figure out the
rest of this [ __ ] oxygen is still a
little lower than it should be but I
don't want to waste too much algae so
I'm gonna let them I'm gonna let them
just carry on for a little bit because I
don't want to get in their way of what
they need to do because I know that they
need to do some things I'm just gonna
put this at a six as well just so they
eventually get to these things here okay
and wow it's working it is it's working
hahahahahaha it's like this contaminated
stuff from the shower and lavatory
flowing out there this is fun in here
we're good everything is happy I'm happy
we're happy everything is good
think everything is good if everything's
not good then I'm gonna be very upset
but I think everything is good I'm
pretty sure I'm fairly certain so if
everything is good then we shouldn't
have any further trouble for the
immediate future we got tons of meal
lice we got lots of food we're doing a
little low on oxygen Ruby is a little
stressed and Natalie probably cuz they
were working in the muck a little bit
but we've got a lot of water flowing
through and this is not bad this is this
is pretty good actually this is not
gonna live I add things out that's some
big old house but I think this is this
might actually work out for me this
might actually work
and then I go over there for the slime
production I let the percolators drop
the frame down into there they'll dig
through there the research just
completed for advanced filtration for
air scrubber gas filter and liquid
filter that's good that's good that's
good that's good that's good that's good
that's good okay
so I'm gonna go for interior decor just
because hey why not give them something
easy that can drop some stress just so
we make sure everybody's stress is just
a little bit down but yeah that son of a
[ __ ] is just going to be pumping all
day long we are going to need eventually
we're going to need more batteries and
we're going to need more people humping
uh for energy because then like they do
need to be there I mean this this filter
is going to take a lot of power over
time it definitely is here we go we've
got to make sure that we got that under
control
but so far I'm actually going to cancel
all this because we don't need that
right now I mean for the slime
collection yeah I'll do it for the slime
collection itself but for everything
else it's not bad this is this is pretty
good I like it I like it it's going well
I'm just trying to look at it and be
like how can everything go horribly
wrong for me how is this terrible
in what way am I going to die so I'm
making this a gas permeable one who
hello newcomer how you doing woo mention
Leeanne EPP can't build that's a problem
okay slow learner
naturally robust I'll take that I'll
take that little destructive but you
know better than the other ones I guess
all right come on in what's your name
BAE your BAE your BAE
Oh BAE okay BAE all right good you silly
Billy
alright BAE you're gonna do me a lot of
good I know you will it's going to be a
great help in everything that we do here
okay so that's got storage compactor so
what I'm about to do is I'm about to
tunnel through a whole bunch of SWAT
which means that I'm going to have to
store the slime but that's okay that's
what we're here they're going to be is
going to be a bit of stress when they
want to do this I know it's a bit of a
dangerous gamble to go here and just
kind of you know work till they drop
style do this but it's going to be worth
it I know it is we're gonna actually
going to have multiple layers of you
know of this of the percolator going so
we're just gonna have adult in oodles
and oodles of it and then you oh there
you are my cash cows you're gonna be
doing me so much good I'll just start
with this one because I don't want to go
overboard because obviously my power
generation isn't going to be nearly
enough to compensate for all of that
stuff but we'll get there when we get
there like I've been saying this whole
time we'll get there when we get there
but at least this plan is coming
together because now I've got this guy
who's happily making slime again which
is awfully nice and eventually we'll cut
through to this guy oh there's three of
them did I notice there were three of
them before but there's three of them
which is even better because then we'll
make all the slime we could possibly
want so we should have tons and tons and
tons and tons of crime so now I'm going
to pry our - oh we got some stress guys
Ruby is real stressed but not quite that
bad yet get in there but not quite there
yet we will get there all right making
lots of liquid conduits alright so
everything else is going pretty okay
except we're completely out of
and that's not good because we're not
producing oxygen oh is that out oh we
got when did we get more algae we got
984 that just went up all the sudden I
don't know I'm not complaining though
it's like if we just suddenly spawn more
algae that'll be better than what
happened in the last episode or in the
plastic last game session that we had
all right so those are almost just about
done very close to the end of doneness
just about there almost done this was so
close to being done so close come on
just a little more what are they doing
oh no power that's what they're doing
about last what networks we're okay good
good good okay now do your thing do your
thing gang do your thing you don't need
to worry about all that you do your
thing you relax relax Ruby calm down
Ruby Jesus Ruby Ruby calm down okay
should be all right everything's fine Oh
new guy all right fine then we need to
watch out because we're starting to use
a lot more oxygen than we were before
all right nope we don't want that okay
so the Bulls going to be dimensionally
inept I guess they could do other stuff
a mozzarella oh no I just remembered
mozzarella from the last one okay all
right then mozzarella you come on come
on down oh you're so sweet how are you
guys doing oh you're collecting slime
okay well that's I'm gonna put that as
like a five priority we don't need too
many people rushing out there until
later but what we do need yeah we are
starting to use a lot more oxygen than
we were I mean we definitely need to get
the power up that's one thing that
definitely needs to happen we do have a
lot of I don't know why but we have a
lot of contaminated oxygen up here and
I'm not 100% sure why where did that
come from
like what's causing the contaminated
oxygen buildup over here is it just like
something slipped by and then it got up
here because if that is the case then it
go away like over time but I just want
to make sure that's not going to be
killing anybody I mean it's not just not
going to kill anybody I never did but I
want to make sure that they doesn't make
anybody go crazy no I'm just gonna build
one of these because there's really no
harm in having another one over here I
don't want people grieving contaminated
oxygen all day Ruby you're so stressed
with you know you're doing great
everybody's getting a little more
stressed and they're getting a lot more
stress than I would like don't like that
a lot but we will deal with it as best
we can all we can do that's all we can
do the stress vomited oh did Ruby do it
and then run away from her
responsibilities that were Ruby did
[Music]
okay we did it okay so we got that
research done now so that'll be a little
bit better
oh that's not good with that country
okay but we have that made so now we can
make a cold generator and that's going
to be able to provide us with just a bit
more it will provide it will produce a
lot of carbon dioxide down here
but over here once again not that big a
deal I think we can survive it okay -
for now - for now we'll see how that
goes we do have a lot of coal but you
know I just I I think - one is pretty
much equivalent to maybe two of the
wheels I have no idea either way it
should probably produce more power I
just want to make sure that we're good
on all our power but it seems like these
guys have actually been running so much
they're almost full holy [ __ ] well done
if you did AA good stress reliever
gabriele doing good Ruby stuff needs a
lot of help Ruby
what does Ruby do all rubies are you
over here Ruby and you see over here I
don't even know where you went Ruby
where'd you go all right I'm still
worried about our oxygen situation
because it's getting a little lower than
I would ever want oh good more people ok
little hesitant to get another person in
here just yet narcoleptic neidell I'll
take that Oh take that I'll take that
yeah that'll be good hello grubbé how
are you thinking for your name is not
grubbles oh no your name is Grubb holy
crap your name is Grubb I didn't even
check that I'm sorry I didn't pay
attention to that Grubb hello nails Bay
Ellie
Neal all right you guys have wonderful
love you lot
mmm okay those are going pretty well
yeah I'm producing a lot of carbon
dioxide but that's gonna fall down and
then hopefully everything will be okay
all right so that's going to solve our
power problem I'm hoping that those
things will stop no that that they won't
stop
oh yeah they're not going to stop are
they so I need to get more batteries to
be able to take advantage of those coal
generators so we got to get like a whole
huge Bank of them just so we know
lashing out who's lashing out the neck
is so stressed that they're lashing out
who did that
what god dammit of course they go for
the same thing they always do the one
thing they need to survive
Jesus well just stupid idiots okay so
stress is going down a bit stress is
going down we've got these big old
batteries there that are going to be
banking all this extra power from that
so we're doing pretty ok let's think
yeah yeah we're doing pretty okay so we
got all those which means that we should
be able to continue these we can enable
these now then let's try to mop up all
this [ __ ] remember [ __ ] down here let's
mop it up mop it up and then we should
be good so things should be rolling a
bit better now we are getting a good
amount of algae we had a good amount of
energy well we've got a good amount of
slime and then as we continue on with
those percolators we'll be able to
create more and more algae from the
infinite supply of slime that this pup
is going to be consuming and emitting
lots and lots of that [ __ ] that's good
and then I'm going to make another
shower for these lovely people so they
don't have to suffer
and the [ __ ] okay 99 time you guys
go to beddy-bye
you guys go to beddy-bye you guys go to
beddy-bye okay so I think we are doing
pretty well this is a good launching
point it seems to be relatively balanced
I've got power I've got food I could
always make more food overheated it
really it's overheated there probably
because I got all these electronics over
here that I don't necessarily need I
might have to move those around it's
nice and cool down here but there's no
oxygen I'll see about fixing that in the
next episode obviously it cools down
whatever it's fine it fluctuates a bit
and it's not the worst thing in the
world but we will see about getting this
all sorted unreachable is it unreachable
well if you dig here so those are gonna
those are going to suck the contaminated
air out that should work out pretty well
we got a newcomer I don't know if I want
a newcomer I'll leave that for another
episode I think we're in a good stopping
point right now plenty of food all this
other stuff there possibly free to do
that [ __ ] which I sign them to do that
ages ago but it seems to be okay we
don't have to we will get filtration
medium for that one very soon yeah
should be okay we still got some stress
people and I don't like that I don't
like that at all I think I'm gonna have
to lashing out oh [ __ ] where are you
laughing out Lee Leslie of course Eugene
good job okay but that's fine because
what I'm going to do next is I'm gonna
build a mess so that they can at least
have a nice place to eat someone's
lashing out the stress is pretty high I
wish it wasn't I wish it wasn't I'm not
100% sure why it is so high but
I guess it can't be helped for now so
I'm going to pause this right here we're
at the cusp of controlling this because
once it starts to get big it starts to
get harder and harder to control the
oxygen is getting a little lower we're
running a little bit out of algae like
the percolators aren't producing as much
algae as I would like but the concept of
the water filters and purifiers are
solid so long as those are running we'll
have enough water to say make into
oxygen directly which would be nice but
we shall see so thank you everybody so
much for watching I hope you've been
enjoying this thus far I will get back
to this game in the future I think I've
laid it out for today but I hope you
guys enjoyed a lot because I am and it's
only in pre-alpha so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]
Oh